مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوينها
ارسال بريطانيا لقذائف اليورانيوم الى
اوكرانيا ينقل الصراع الى مرحله جديده
قانون المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
والقوانين الاخرى
مرزوق الغانم يدعو الى مفوضيه للانتخابات
في الكويت ويؤكد ان البلاد تسير في حلقه
مفرغه
رابعات تواكب التجارب البحثيه لرائدي
الفضاء السعوديين تمهيدا لرحله الفضاء
المقرره في مايو المقبل
الرابعه ايضا
مع حلول شهر رمضان 400 حافله تنقل
للمعتمرين والزوار في مكه بشكل مجاني
وجدها تحتفي بعام الشعر العربي بيومسيه
للشاعر الشهير ادونيس وسط حضور كبير
تصعيد قضاء في اليورانيوم لا يهدئ حيث حضر
وزير الخارجيه روسي سيرجي لافروف من ان
قرار بريطانيا تزويد اوكرانيا بقضاءك من
اليورانيوم المنظم يساعد الموقف والصراع
الى مستويات جديده وخطيره وسيؤدي ذلك الى
عواقب وخيمه على علاقات موسكو ولندن على
حد تعبيره
من جهتي اكد وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كليفر لان تزويد كييف بقذائف اليورانيوم
المنظم ليست صعيدا نوويا كما تقول روسيا
اشار الى ان الدوله الوحيده التي تتحدث عن
التصعيد النووي والتسعى اليه كيا روسيا
قبل ذلك حضر وزير الدفاع من انصدام النووي
محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل متبقيه قبل حدوث
هذا الصدام بين روسيا والغرب وفق ما نقلته
وكاله
تحضير شويغو بعدما سئل من الصحفيين اما
اذا كانت نيه بريطانيا من تزويد اوكرانيا
بقذائف اليورانيوم المنضب تعني ان العالم
قد بات على بعد خطوه واحده من حدوث صدام
النووي
الدفاع الروسيه ايضا اعلن الانتهاء من
تحديث منظومه الدفاع الجوي الروسي بنهايه
العام الجاري واشار خلال اجتماع مع قيادات
الوزاره الى ان خطط التحديث تشمل نشر
انظمه للدفاع الجوي في احدى جزر الكوريلا
المتنازع عليها مع اليابان واشار الى ان
القوات الجويه دمرتها اكثر من 20 الف
منشاه في اوكرانيا نفذت اكثر من 140 الف
طلع
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
طعمها مرحبا بك اولا في وجهه النظر
الروسيه كيف يمكن قراءه تداعيات اتخاذ
خطوه امداد اوكرانيا بالايرانيوم او
بقنابل اليورانيوم المنظم من بريطانيا
طبعا خالد ردود الافعال الروسيه الرسميه
لا تتوقف منذ يوم امس اولا وزير وزير
الدفاع الروسي كان قد تحدث ان العالم تقدم
خطوه جديده نحو حرب عالميه او حرب نوويه
مواجهه نوويه بعد اعلام بريطانيا رغبتها
في تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه القذائف قذائف
اليورانيوم طبعا الرئيس الروسي كان ايضا
قد قال ان روسيا سترد على اي خطوه من هذا
النوع
برد مماثل وزير الخارجيه سريه اليوم كان
قد قال ان روسيا ملتزمه بالعقيده النوويه
بوابير معاهده النوويه التي دعا اليها يوم
امس ايضا الرئيسان الصيني والروسي كان قد
دعى خلال البيان النهائي للقائه بالالتزام
بالمعاهده النوويه وضروره عدم ارسال الدول
التي تحتوي على سلاح نووي الى ارس هذه
الاسلحه الى دول ثالثه وفي حال ارسالها
يجب ان تقوم بسحب هذه الاسلحه وزير خارجيه
روسيس اليوم اكد على ان هذه الاسلحه ستؤذي
اوكرانيا بالدرجه الاولى اولا قد تؤدي الى
نشر الامراض هناك وستؤثر على البيئه
والتربه وعلى طبيعه الغذاء التي تنتجه
اوكرانيا وكما تعلم خالد ان اوكرانيا هي
تقوم بانتاج حبوب الذي يصدر الى كافه
انحاء العالم وهذا ما تحدث عنه وزير خارجي
الروسي هذه خطوه تصعيديه جديده من جانب
الغرب ومن جانب حلف الناتو قد تؤدي الى
مواجهه طبعا مع جانب الروسي في حال بدات
القوات الاوكرانيه باستخدام
من نوع مثل هذه القذائف النوويه
رومانسيه يمكن ان تتخذ الان من قبل
حقيقه روسيا كما تحدثت كما قال وزير
الخارجيه الروسي وكما تحدثت ايضا يوم امس
خلال بيانها للرئتين الصيني والروسي قال
انهما طبعا
بمعاهده الالتزام بالاسلحه عدم انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه لذلك حتى الان روسيا فقط
تقوم بالتهديد وهذا ليس وليست للمره
الاولى التي تقوم روسيا طبعا
بالتهديد في حال كان هناك تهديد يمثل
لموسكو او تهديد كبير يشكل لموسكو من قبل
الغرب بانها ستقوم بالرد بالمثل ولكن حتى
الان هي فقط التصعيد هو فقط كلامي ولم يتم
طبعا ولم ينعكس على الارض لم تقر روسي
انها ايضا ستقوم باستخدام هذه الاسلحه على
الارض لذلك هو فقط تصعيد سياسي الان من
الجانب الروسي حتى تبدا في حال استخدمت
اوكرانيا هذه الاسلحه وكما تحدث الخبراء
بان فعل فعلا ان العالم قد يجهد حرب
عالميه ثانيه عفوا ثالثه في حال استخدامات
اوكرانيا هذه الخزائف شكرا
في التطورات الميدانيه للحرب في اوكرانيا
زار الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
مواقع عسكريه للجيش بالقرب من باخموت
الواقعه على خط المواجهه مع القوات
الروسيه في شرق اوكرانيا والتي تعد مسرحا
لاشرس واطول المعارك بين كييف وموسكو منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
تعرض مبنى سكني في منطقه زابوريجيا في شرق
اوكرانيا الى قصف صاروخي وتمت اوكرانيا
روسيا بقصف المبنى وقال الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلنسكي ان روسيا تقصف زابولوجيا بوحشيه
تضرب مناطق سكنيه يعيش فيها الناس
العاديون والاطفال
حتى المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصيني
على تصحيح سلوكها في القضيه الاوكرانيه
والتوقف عن القاء اللوم على الصين مؤكدا
ستواصل دورها لايجاد حل سياسي للقضيه
الاوكرانيه
نحث الولايات المتحده على دراسه دورها في
القضيه الاوكرانيه وتصحيح سلوكها الخاطئ
المتمثل في صب الزيت على النار والتوقف عن
القاء اللوم على الصين سنواصل الوقوف بحزم
الى جانب السلام والحوار والصواب التاريخي
والعمل بشكل بناء مع المجتمع الدولي
لمواصله دورنا في تعزيز حل سياسي للقضيه
الاوكرانيه
يعقد وزراء خرجات دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي اجتماع الدوره 155
للمجلس الوزاري لدول الخليج العربيه في
مقر الامانه بالرياض وسيتناول الاجتماع
العلاقات الخليجيه الخليجيه في ملفات
اقتصاديه وتعليميه وصحيه وغيرها بالاضافه
الى تناول ابرز مستجدات القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه برئاسه دوله عمان
في الرابعه بعد قليل
نيورو مبنى في العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
قتيل واحد وانقاذ سبعه اشخاص من تحت
الانقم
اهلا بكم من جديد انهار مبنى في العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه ما ادى الى سقوط جزء من
المبنى على مبنى اخر مجاور اصفر انهيار
المبنى عن اكثر شخص واحد على الاقل فيما
يستمر البحث وسط الحطام عن ناجين بحسب
السلطات القطريه وقد اوضحت وزاره الداخليه
القطريه ان المبنى مكون من اربعه طوابق
ويقع في حي بن درهم اضافت ان رجال الانقاذ
عثروا على سبعه نجيم وقتيل واحد داخل
المبنى
الكويت الى اين تساؤل مستمر بعد قرار
المحكمه الدستوريه الصادم ببطلان مجلس
الامه المنتخب في العام الماضي 2022 وعوده
مرزوق الغانم لرئاسه المجلس مجددا الغانم
دعا في مؤتمر عقده بمقر المجلس بالامثله
اقرار قانون المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
مؤكدا ان النواب
ومؤازرتهم للحكومه مرتبط
بصدقها في وعودها عبر برنامجها الشامل في
وقت لا تزال فيه الحكومه حكومه تسير اعمال
رئيس مجلس الامه العائد الى منصبه مرزوق
الغانم قال ان الكويت لا تزال في ذات
الدوامه والحلقه المفرغه وسط حاله احباط
يعيشها البعض مع تغير المجالس والحكومات
على حد قوله
لا يخفى على احد حاله الاحباط لذاك قطاع
كبير من ابناء الشعب الكويتي اذ تغيرت
المجلس وتغيرت الحكومات ولا نزال في نفس
الدوامه والحلقه المفرزه وهذا يدفعني الى
التاكيد على نقطه مفصليه وهي ان المساله
ليست مجلس 20 او 22 وليس مرزوق الغانم او
السيد احمد السعدون الموضوع ليس شيخان
الفاضلان صباح الخالد او احمد النواف
القضيه اكبر من تلك الثنائيات المظلله
والمتخيله والقاصره اذ هي قضيه خطاب
سياسيه تمتع بالوعي والبصيره وممارسه
ناضجه قوامها الموضوعات والملفات لا
الاشخاص والاسماء وهما عمران يستهدفان
شيئا واحدا وهو تعزيز شعور المواطنه في
نفوس الناس واعاده ايمانهم في بلدهم
ومستقبله وهذا لن يتاتى الا ببرنامج عمل
وطني يتحقق اجماع الامه عليه
من الكويت انضم الينا الصحفي محمد السبتي
سيد محمد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
كل سنه وانت طيب بمناسبه شهر رمضان
المبارك خليني ابدا معك بالرسائل التي
اراد مرزوق الغانم
توجيهها في خطاب الامس ولمن كانت هذه
الرسائل موجه
حقيقه في ظن انه لا رسائل موجهه هو كلام
لا يعدو ان يكون تنظير شبعنا منه سماعا
منذ فتره طويله هذا الكلام غير قابل
للتطبيق عندما نتكلم عن وعي سياسي كيف
نحصل على هذا الوعي السياسي هل هناك دواء
يشربه المجتمع مثلا فينتج عنه وعيا سياسيا
تكلم السيد مرزوق الغانم عن ممارسه سياسيه
مسؤوله كيف نحصل على هذه
الممارسه السياسيه المسؤوله الكل ينشد تلك
الاهداف ولا احد منا يستطيع
الوصول الى تلك الاهداف لانها اقرب الى
الاماني منها الى الاهداف التي يمكن
تحقيقها وفق المعطيات هذا شعبنا وتلك
كتلًا وسياسيه وهذا طبيعه تفكيرينا
وعقولنا في ممارسه هذه العمليه الانتخابيه
وهذه نتائجها
التنظير لا يعني شيئا لذلك اليوم الخلاف
المعضله
الماساه التي تعيشه الكويت سياسيا بين
الحكومه والمجلس بين المجلس والمجلس هناك
خلاف وخلاف شديد
ويعني انسداد للافق بين المجلس ذاته بين
كتل وكتل الخلاف لم يكن حكوميا مع المجلس
بل كان مع المجلس مع المجلس ما هي الحلول
لهذه الازمه ولهذه الخلافات الجواب لا
حلول لا تطرح حلول ما طرحه السيد رئيس
مجلس الامه لا يعني شيئا على الناحيه
العمليه حتى العمليه السياسيه التي تحدثت
عنها مساله انتخابات العوده الى
المواطن الكويتي
القرارات المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
النظام لا يمكن ان تتخذ كطريق للمعالجه
يعني لنفرض مثلا ما طرحه السيد مرزوق
الغانم بضروره انشاء المفوضيه العليا
للانتخابات لماذا اليوم لما حل مجلس الامه
لم يكن بسبب ماخذ وشبهات يعني حامت حول
العمليه الانتخابيه تم حل مجلس الامه
لوجود خلل في مرسوم الحل لا في وجود خلل
اصابع العمليه الانتخابيه لم يكن يوما من
الايام حلم مجلس الامه ثلاث مرات هذه مره
والمرتين السابقتين في ال2012 كل تلك
الحلول التي جاءت من المحكمه الدستوريه
بطلان عمليه الانتخاب لم تكن بسبب وجود
خلل في العمليه الانتخابيه بل بسبب وجود
خلل في المراسيم الاميريه التي تصدر من
الحكومه بحل مجلس الامه لذلك المفوضيه
الانتخابيه وان كانت مناداه حق لا ننكر
انها مناداه حق وانها ضروره لكنها لا تحل
مشكله لان
وجود الخلل او عدم وجود الخلل يحل ب 60
الف طريقه قد تكون واليوم يعل جميع ان من
يقوم بزمام الامور بالاشراف على العمله
الانتخابيه هي السلطه القضائيه كذلك الا
ان مطرحه السيد مرزوق الغانم بالاشاره الى
ضروره الاستعجال باقرار قانون المفوضيه
الانتخابيه كانه يشير الى ان الانتخابات
التي مضت يعني كان فيها خللا كبيرا وان لم
يقر احدا لم تقر الاحكام القضائيه بوجود
مثل هذا الخلل بل ولم تناقشه اصلا لان كان
الخلل بوجود تلك المراسيم الاميريه التي
صدرتها الحكومه بعلم مجلس الامه لذلك قلت
في البدايه ان هذا كلام لا يعدو ان يكون
تمظيرا سياسيا
لا ناتجه من ورائه في حل تلك الازمه
والمعضله والدوامه التي اشار اليها رئيس
مجلس الامه يعيش المجتمع منذ سنوات وتلك
وهذا التنظير لا يحلها ابدا افق المشكله
الان الى اين يتجه في ظل حاله الاحتراب
الصراع مع النواب مواقفهم يعني اكثر من
نائب كانوا انتقدوا ما قاله الغانم مثل
الدكتور عبد العزيز السقعه على سبيل
المثال قال بان الغانم لا يبحث عن
انتخابات مزينه نزيهه ويبحث عن شراء الوقت
فقط لاحياء مجلس منتهي شعبيا تصريحات ايضا
جاءت على لسان عبد الكريم الكندري كذلك
عبيد الوسمي الذي قال ان كان هناك من زور
فلماذا فلماذا تم التزوير ويجب ان نعرف من
هو ولمصلحه من ما رايك في مثل هذا الكلام
كل كل تلك الاطروحات لا تعني لا يعني
[موسيقى]
لتنشيط وممارسه اهداف شخصيه عند هؤلاء
الكتل السياسيه ليس الا تلك الاطروحات لا
يمكن بحال ان تحل تلك الازمه السياسيه
التي نعانيها انت على فرض جدلا اننا
اجرينا انتخابات مبكره بالغد مثلا ثم جاء
مجلس امه بانتخابات لا يعني ليس فيها
شائبه هل يتوقع احد في الكويت هناك مليون
و400 الف مواطن كويتي لا احد من هؤلاء
المليون واربعمائه الف يتوقع ان ينتج من
تلك الانتخابات ناتج ايجابي في العمليه
السياسيه مارسناها من قبل نحن نجرب الذي
جربناه المشكله ليس في انتخابات مبكره
المشكله ليست في مخرجات انتخابات المشكله
ليست في شخوص من يعين يعني رئيسا للوزراء
او او شخوص النواب هذه هذا يعني هروب من
كل الكتل السياسيه لمواجهه حقيقه المشكله
التي يعانيها المجتمع وهي باختصار هي هذا
النظام الذي النظام الانتخابي الذي
فشل له دون ان المسلمين في الكويت
يعني سالتك هذا السؤال مرارا وتكرارا يعني
خلال
الايام والسنوات القليله الماضيه في حل
ولا لا في الكويت من الاخر
الحل واقعيا يعني نترك تلك الممارسات
عندما يجروا الناس للاسف هنا لا لا واقعين
ليس هناك حل لان الكل اقولها اقولها
وبصراحه الكل يخجل من الاعتراف بفشل
النظام الانتخابي الكل يعتقد ان من المعيب
اليوم هناك حاله في الكويت لا ينبغي لمثقف
ولا لمحامي ولا لكاتب صحفي ان يفكر فقط
التفكير في فشل هذا النظام الانتخابي
يعتبره الناس هنا معيبا لان هناك سطوه على
هذه المناداه اما ان نمارس تلك العمليه
الانتخابيه والا فمن ينادي بغير ذلك هو
دكتاتوري وذنب للسلطه من مسميات هناك سطوه
فكريه من مثل هذه الاطروحات لذلك يخجل
الكثير من الناس ونعاب يعاب امثالنا في كل
مكان في كل منتدى على ما نقوله من
اعترافنا بفشل هذا النظام الانتخابي شكرا
هناك حل اقولها بصراحه ليس هناك حل سوف
نبقى في هذه الدوامه شكرا جزيلا لك من
الكويت الصحفي الكويتي المعروف محمد
السبتي شكرا لك
ونعد التذكير مره اخرى بعقد وزراء خارجيه
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي اجتماع الدوره
155 للمجلس الوزاري للدول الخليج العربي
بمقر الامانه بالرياض تناول الاجتماعي
العلاقات الخليجيه الخليجيه في ملفات
اقتصاديه وتعليميه وصحيه
وغيرها اضافه الى تناول ابرز مستجدات
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه برئاسه عمان
ينضم الينا من مقر اجتماعات وزراء
الخارجيه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي من
الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن مرحبا بك معي مدى في هذا
الاجتماع من ملفات وما المتوقع ايضا في
بياني او في نتائج
نعم خالد بالفعل قبل قليل وتحديدا قبل اقل
من ربع ساعه بدا هذا الاجتماع الذي تراسه
وزير خارجيه العماني بدر البوسعيدي بحكم
ان عمان هي التي تراس المجلس في هذا العام
في دورته الحاليه وبدا الاجتماع بكلمتين
لوزير الخارجيه العماني وكذلك بالاضافه
الى الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
الجديد تحدث عن جاسم البديوي وهو في منصبه
وفي اول اجتماع
يقام في ظل التراسه او تواجده على منصب
الامين
الخليجي
العديد من
حضرناها بعد ذلك لوزير الخارجيه العماني
وجاسم البديوي بعد ذلك اغلقت الجلسات
واصبحت مغلقه اتحدث عن ابرز ما تحدث به
وزير الخارجيه العماني الذي بدا مباشره
بالحديث عن الاتفاق الثلاثي السعودي
الايراني الصيني ببساطه الصينيه وقال
مرحبا بهذا الاتفاق وقال بان هذا الاتفاق
يقود المنطقه بشكل كامل الى مرحله جديده
من العلاقات مع ايران مرحله مبنيه على
الثقه والتكامل وايضا
الجوانب الاخرى التي تحدث عنها في هذا
الاتفاق بالاضافه الى الحديث عن ابرز
القضايا الاخرى التي سيتناولها
المجلس في هذا الاجتماع وربما قضايا
مختلفه سواء كان في قضايا بينيه بين
المجلس وعلى مستوى الملفات الاقتصاديه
المشتركه وحتى الامنيه وايضا الاقتصاديه
بدرجه اولى وتحدث هنا عن الاتحاد الخليجي
ايضا الاتحاد الجمرك الخليجي وكافه
القضايا الاقتصاديه الاخرى التي يرغب
المجلس بتطويرها وتحسينها
القيام بعدد من الخطوات العمليه في هذا
الاطار للوصول الى الاتحاد الخليجي وهو ما
تسعى اليه كافه الدول عبر هذه الاجتماعات
الدوريه الكبيره جدا يوم الامس كان هناك
ايضا اجتماعات كبيره على مستوى اللجان
التي ترفع مباشره
التوصيات الى المجلس الوزاري ومن ثم الى
المجلس الاعلى لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ربما من ابرز القضايا التي تثار وايضا
هناك اهتمام كبير فيها والقطار الخليجي
المشترك ربما يكون هناك حديث من خلال هذا
الاجتماع وايضا بالاضافه الى الاجتماعات
الاخرى بالاضافه الى ذلك كان هنالك حديث
لجاسم البديوي الامين العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي الجديد الذي قال بانه استلم هذه
المهمه ويشكر كافه من
معه في خلال هذه المرحله المهمه بالاضافه
الى حديثه بان هنالك كتل ودول مختلفه من
كافه انحاء العالم تريد ان تعزز علاقاتها
مع المجلس وهو يعمل على ذلك مع كافه
الوزراء وكافه الدول في المجلس بالاضافه
الى حديثه عن القيام بتعزيز العمل الخليجي
المشترك وبالاضافه الى البناء على
النجاحات التي تم تحقيقها سواء كان
الاقتصاديه او غيرها من النجاحات التي
بنيت عليها في المجلس ويريد ان يواصل ذلك
من خلال
امانته للمجلس والتسلمه لهذا المنصب
بالاضافه لذلك سيكون هناك بيان ختامي بعد
هذا الاجتماعي يتوقع بان يتناول كافه
الملفات المواقف من فلسطين من اليمن من
كافه القضايا الدوليه بالاضافه الى ايضا
سيكون هناك حديث لاتفاق السعودي الايراني
الصيني الثلاثي في هذا البيان الختامي
شكرا جزيلا لك من رياض مقر اجتماعات وزراء
الخارجيه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي عبد
المحسن الح
في السعوديات تنطلق غدا حمله منصه جود
الاسكان الخيريه لتامين المساكن للاسر
الاشد احتياجا للمسكن تحت عنوان حمله
اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري الحمله تستهدف
بطبيعتها المجتمع بكافه مؤسساته وافراده
في تامين مبلغ مليار ريال لتامين ما يصل
الى 3500 مسكن للاسر شديده الحاجه تقوم
فكره الحمل على محاكاه فكره
لعوائد ماديه انما عوائد خيريه مجتمعيه
باسهم تبلغ 100 مليون
في الرابع ايضا بعد قليل مع حلول شهر
رمضان 400 حافله تنقل المعتمرين والزوار
في مكه المكرمه بشكل مجاني
يؤكد ان ارسال بريطانيا لقضائف اليورانيوم
الى اوكرانيا ينقل الصراع الى مرحله جديده
اقرار قانون المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
والقوانين الاخرى مرزوق الغانم يدعو الى
مفوضيه للانتخابات في الكويت ويؤكد ان
البلاد تسير في حلقه المفرغه
الرابعه تواكب التجارب البحثيه الفضاء
السعوديين تمهيدا لرحله الفضاء المقرره في
مايو المقبل
ومع حلول شهر رمضان 400 حافله تنقل
المعتمرين والزوار في مكه بشكل مجاني
ايتها الضاد الضاد يا لغه
وجده تحتفي بعام الشعر العربي بامسيه
للشاعر السوري الشهير ادونيس وسط حضور
كبير
اهلا بكم من جديد زارت سفيره السعوديه لدى
واشنطن الاميره ريما بنت بندر ايدي الفضاء
السعوديين علي القرني وريان برناوي في
مركز التحكم الخاص بمهمه سبيس اكس التي
تنظمها وكاله الفضاء
قالت الاميره ريما في تغريده لها انها
قامت بجوله في مرافق المركز وشاهدت رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين خلال التدريب وشادت
بالرائده ريان التي تعد اول رائده فضاء
عربيه مسلمه
14 تجربه بحثيه تجريها الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء للتاهيل رائدى الفضاء السعوديين
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني لاستكشاف وتطوير
مجالات مختلفه قبل المغادره الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه في الثاني عشر من مايو
المقبل التجارب البحثيه مصممه عبر علماء
وباحثين بهدف اجتياز متطلبات التاهيل
لبرنامج رواد الفضاء السعوديين واستيفائي
معايير التقييم
من احد مختبرات الفضاء في رياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نصفيا مرحبا هاني كل سنه
وانت طيب حدثنا اكثر عن هذه التجارب التي
تقام لرواد الفضاء
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اليوم نتحدث عن السعوديه تطمح
بوصول بحوثها الى الفضاء واقامه ايضا
تجارب هي اربعه عشر تجربه بحثيه سوف
تستخدمها السعوديه وسوف تقوم بها من خلال
عمليه تدريب لرائدي الفضاء الذين سوف
يقومون بتجربه هذه البحوث من هذه البحوث
هي في مجالات عده طبعا ولكن اليوم نتحدث
عن المجالات الطبيه وتحديدا من داخل هذا
المختبر الواقع في مستشفى الملكه او مركز
الابحاث في مستشفى الملك فيصل للبحوث
العلميه يقوم هؤلاء العلماء وكذلك
الاطباء وكذلك بعض
البروفيسوريين الموجودين في هذا المختبر
باقامه تجربه البحوث العلميه عموما في هذا
الامر سوف يتحدث معي ضيفي وهو الدكتور
خالد ابو خبر وهو رئيس قسم الجزيئات
الطبيه وكذلك الحيويه في مستشفى الملك
فيصل اليوم نتكلم عن بحوث الطبيه وفي
مجالات اخرى ولكن دائما نتحدث عن البحوث
الطبيه ما هي هذه البحوث كيف سوف تقدمونها
كيف سوف يتم تجربتها في الفضاء كيف سوف
يتم ايضا عملها وايجاد هذه النتائج من
خلال البحوث
احنا نستخدم نماذج خلويه للمرض
وبالاخص معرفه استجابه الخلايا المناعيه
للالتهاب
وفي نفس الوقت نفهم التغييرات في عمق عمر
الحمل الربو المراسل وكيفيه ايضا
الاستجابه للعلاج الدوائي عشان نقارن
بينهم بين الفضاء وبين وبين
وبين الارض كمقارنه نعم يعني يا دكتور
اليوم نتكلم بشكل سلس يعني اليوم انتم
تقومون بالتجارب وتشوف وترون هل هي موائمه
لجسم الانسان في الفضاء كما هي في الارض
ام لا يعني بشكل بالضبط بالضبط يعني في في
عده يعني نتائج نتوقع احنا نتوقع صراحه
يعني كميات هايله من المعلومات عن نشاط
عشرات الالاف من الجينات وكيف تتغير بين
الفضاء وبين وبين الارض
ان شاء الله فيها تغير اكيد
ما نعرف
يعني هو هذا المحك في الموضوع وفي جميع
الاحوال كلها عباره عن يعني مهمه سواء
اتغيرت باقل او تغيرت اكثر لانه يعطينا
فكره عن كيفيه
استخدام سواء نقص عمر الحمض الربيع النووي
او زاد طيب كما تشاهد عزيزي خالد ومشاهدي
قناه العربيه هذه هذا المختبر والذي نشاهد
الان ترصد كاميرا العربيه من داخل هذا
المختبر كاول كاميرا ترصد من داخل مختبر
طبي لبرنامج رواد الفضاء وهي الهيئه
السعوديه
الفضاء التي تقوم بالاشراف على هذه
التجارب البحثيه ونشاهد ايضا كادر طبي
كامل يقوم باجراء عده بحوث يعني اليوم يا
دكتور نتكلم ونشاهد الان نرصد كاميرا
العربيه هذه البحوث ولكن هناك سؤال مهم
رايدي الفضاء ريانه وعلي
ليس مختصين طبيا وليس هم ايضا دكاتره او
يعملون في المجال الطبي كيف سوف يتم ايصال
او كيف سوف يتم تطبيق هذه البحوث في
الفضاء سؤال جيد سؤال جيد في الحقيقه الان
تقوم الدكتور وجدان الاحمدي هي احد اعضاء
الفريق العلمي موجود الان بولايه كلور
كلورايد بامريكا لعمل محاكاه باستخدام نفس
التجهيزات ونفس المستلزمات الموجوده في
المحطه الدوليه الفضائيه عشان نتاكد بكل
دقه
وايضا بالوقت ثم بعد ذلك تم تدريب رائده
الفضاء ورائده الفضاء على على هذه على نفس
التجارب هذا الذي يقومون الذي سيقومون
فيها في المحطه الفضائيه الدولية كنا
نتكلم يا دكتور انه بعض الاجهزه المستخدمه
في هذا المختبر هي اجهزه نوعيه السعوديه
من دول القلائل التي تمتلك هذه الاجهزه
هو اهم شيء صراحه النواحي العلميه فاحنا
متخصصين في عمر الحمض الريب النووي
المناسب المعروفين داني دوليا في الموضوع
هذا وعلى سبيل
المثال يعني
قمنا بغسل التغييرات اللي حاصله في
السرطان وفي الالتهابات والان حان الان
المعرفه اللي ممكن تحصل في الفضاء شكرا لك
يا دكتور خالد رغم ان الحديث شيق معك هو
حديث طبي بحث ولكن سوف نسهل الامر
للمشاهدين اليوم السعوديه عندها عده بحوث
طبيه وفي مجالات مختلفه ايضا ولكن بما
اننا نتواجد في مختبر طبي اليوم هؤلاء
الباحثين وكذلك الفريق البحثي هو يقوم
بتجربه بعض الخصائص لجسم الانسان وكيف هي
مواءمتها عندما يكون في الفضاء وايضا من
خلال بعض استخدام الجينات وبعض
الامور او الطرق البحثيه الطبيه طبعا
العربيه كانت تواكب ايضا ترصد عمليه
استخدام هذه العناصر وهذه الجزيئات
الحيويه داخل هذا المختبر الواقع في مركز
الملك فيصل او في مركز الابحاث في مستشفى
الملك فيصل في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وكذلك ايضا لا ننسى ان هناك مختبرات اخرى
داخل السعوديه تقوم السعوديه
بتنفيذ مجالات اخرى سواء مجالات جيولوجيه
او كذلك مجالات في بيئيه وكذلك في
العمليات الحيويه او العمليات والمتغيرات
المناخيه التي تطرا على العالم الان و
داخل الك ره الارضيه
مع حلول شهر رمضان تتزايد العروض الوهميه
للتخفيضات في السلع الاساسيه وزاره
التجاره السعوديه تنفذ جولات رقابيه
مستمره لضمانها باستقرار الاسعار ووفره
المواد
الغذائيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
[موسيقى]
السعر والوفره هاجس كل عام مع حلول شهر
رمضان ما دعى لتكثيف الجولات الرقابيه
التي تقوم بها وزاره التجاره السعوديه على
متاجر التموين واسواق النفع العام للتاكد
من وفره السلع الغذائيه الاساسيه ومراقبه
العروض الترويجيه بلا شك ان وفره السلع
الرمضانيه والعروض الرمضانيه تؤثر على
المجتمع بشكل مباشر او بشكل غير مباشر
وذلك عن طريق ما يسمى بالعقل الجمعي او
الثقافه السائده ولا نكر دور الاعلانات
والدعايات في وارفاء الطابع الرمضاني على
السلع في
مدى تاثيرها على المستهلك هذه الجولات
تهدف الى رصد المؤثرات على حركه العرض
والطلب وتلبيه اي زياده مطلوبه والتاكد من
سلامه وصلاحيه السلع المعروضه للاستهلاك
والهدف منها اسعار مستقره وسلع متوفره بكل
مكان اروحه قاعد اشوف وزاره التجاره بشكل
ملحوظ
ما شاء الله قاعدين يعني يرغبون كل قضيه
لو صار فيه اي شيء يجون اسرع وقت وينحل كل
الام تنحل يعني كل الامور ما شاء الله
توفر العروض والعروض موجوده بكثره
الاسعار ما شاء الله في المتناول بمناسبه
الشهر الكريم العروض كلها يعني على قدر
الحدث موجود بكثره وفيره جدا في عروض
افري وير
وعروض كثير حلوه وكل شيء موجود وزاره
التجاره حددت التراخيص الكترونيه الزاميه
لتخفيضات شهر رمضان للحد من العروض
الوهميه وسط اقبال كبير معتاد على المتاجر
في الشهر الفضيل عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مدينه الخبر العربيه
موسم عمر ضخم ستشهد مكه المكرمه مع حلول
شهر رمضان حيث كشفت الهيئه الملكيه لمكه
المكرمه والمشاعر المقدسه عن تخصيص 400
حافله لنقل المعتمرين والزوار بشكل مجاني
اكثر من سبعه ملايين راكب من المتوقع ان
تنقلهم الحافله المخصصه عبر 438 محطه
موزعه في احياء مكه ما يعني ان اعداد
الركاب اليوميه ستتجاوز 230 الف راكب
ارقام الحافلات وركاب في رمضان لهذا العام
تعد اكبر بخمسه اضعاف من العام الماضي
وكانت انذاك عدد الحافلات 80 حافله فقط
من احدى محطات النقل العام في مكه ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه السلطان السلمي سلطان
مرحبا بك كل سنه وانت طيب كيف ستبدو
الرحله اليوم بالنسبه للمعتمر والزائر في
رمضان هذا العام عبر حافلات النقل الجماعي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك خالد وكل عام وانت ومشاهدي نشره
الرابعه بخير نتحدث على اكثر من 400 حافله
تجول شوارع مكه الرئيسيه والفرعيه
وتغطي كافه المراكز والاحياء الخاصه
بالعاصمه المقدسه وكذلك هنالك محطات
مجاوره بالقرب من الحرم المكي لايصال
المعتمرين والزوار نتواجد حاليا في احدى
اكثر المحطات ازدحاما وكثافه للمعتمرين
والمصلين وتحديدا بجوار مسجد التنعيم هذا
المسجد الذي او مسجد عائشه رضي الله عنها
يحرص كثير من المعتمرين والمصلين زياره
هذا المسجد للصلاه وزيارته ومشاهدته
وتوثيق لحظاتهم لذلك يحرص المعتمرين خصوصا
من الخارج على زياره هذه المواقع نتحدث
على حافلات تجوب شوارع مكه المكرمه تقوم
بنقل المعتمرين والمصلين وكذلك حتى
الركابه وسكان مكه نشاهد الان احدى
الحافلات يعني
امامنا نشاهد بشكل كبير جدا اعداد ضخمه من
المعتمرين يحرصون على التنقل عبر هذه
الحافلات المزوده باعلى التقنيات
والامكانيات ووسائل الراحه وكذلك مزوده
بالكاميرات والانترنت وايضا كافه الوسائل
الامنه لايصال المعتمرين من والى المحطات
كذلك نتحدث على ارقام كبيره شهدها هذا
العام نتحدث على اكثر من 37 مليون شخص
استفاد من حافلات مكه في شهر مارس فقط
وهذا رقم يعتبر كبير جدا لا سيما مكه
المكرمه تشهد ازدحامات
بشريه كبيره من قبل المعتمرين والمصلين في
هذه المنطقه المحطات تنتشر عبر 12 مسار في
في اغلب الاماكن الاكثر حيويه وزياره من
قبل المعتمرين المصلين ايضا هنالك 12
نتحدث به طول يصل الى
560 كيلو متر عبر 438 محطه ارقام كبيره
تعمل عليها حافلات لذلك تعتمد القطاعات
الامنيه او الجهات الخدميه في الحرم المكي
الاعتماد بشكل كبير جدا على هذه الحافلات
في خطط نقلهم للمعتمرين المصلين طوال شهر
رمضان من والى الحرم المكي وكذلك التنقل
الى المرافق السكنيه الخاصه بالمعتمرين
لذلك يحرس المعتمر القادم من الخارجه وحتى
من الداخل ان يعني يقوم بركوب هذه الحافله
المزوده بمقاعد لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
وكذلك هنالك امكانيات كبيره داخل هذه
الحافله الاستفاده منها بشكل مجاني كما
تشاهدون اعداد كبيره وازدحامات كبيره تشهد
هذه المنطقه لا سيما مع قرب دخول شهر
رمضان نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من مكه
المكرمه تحديدا من احدى محطات النقل العام
مراسل العربيه سلطان السوداني
اطلقت وزاره الثقافه السعوديه مبادره
الحروف الطباعيه عبر ابتكار ثلاثه خطوط
سعوديه فريده من نوعها تحمل اسماء مقتبسه
من القاموس المحلي بهدف الاحتفاء بالثقافه
المحليه العرض التالي يوضح الخطوط
الثلاثاء وسر تسميتها واستخداماتها
المتابعه
وزاره الثقافه السعوديه تطلق مبادره
الحروف الطباعيه عبر ابتكار ثلاثه خطوط
سعوديه فريده من نوعها تحمل اسماء مقتبسه
من القاموس المحلي
الخطوط السعوديه الجديده تاتي احتفاء
بالثقافه السعوديه اولها خط المصمك الذي
يتميز بوضوح الملامح وسهوله القراءه وتنسب
تسميته الى قصر المصمك التاريخي خط النسيب
ثاني الخطوط المستحدثه مستوحى من ملاحظات
خط اليد ويناسب الادب والشعر وقصص الاطفال
ناتي الان الى خط الوتد اخر الخطوط التي
استحدثتها وزاره الثقافه السعوديه ماخوذ
من وتد الخيمه بسبب زواياه المنحنيه التي
تشبه وتدا زوايا الخيام يتصف بديناميكيه
الحركه ويناسب نصوص المهرجانات والمناسبات
الرياضيه
في جده نظمت اكاديميه الشعر العربي امسيا
شعريه بالتزامن مع عام الشهر العربي 2023
اطلقته وزاره الثقافه بحضور الشاعر السوري
ادرس تضمنت الامسيه حضور الكثير من
الادباء والشعراء على مسرح جامعه الاعمال
والتكنولوجيا
بالماء
وانسكبوا في جرن احزاني اتشبه بالافق
واصعب الى ذروه رغباتي في جده اخر محطات
جولته السعوديه الشاعر والمفكر الشهير
شارك السعوديين احتفاءهم بعام الشعر
العربي
2023 بامسيه شهدت حضورا جماهريا كبيرا
حينما قدم الى السعوديه احنا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اردنا من خلال هذا
الحضور وهذه الزياره احداث حراك ثقافي
مناقشات امسيات شعريه نلتقي ببقامه علميه
وشعريه وادبيه معروفه وراقيه وقدمت
للثقافه العربيه الشيء الكثير
ايتها الضاد الضاد
يا بيتي قصائد وحكايا من الشعر العربي زين
بها ادونيس امسيته في جده فضلا عن معزوفات
غنائيه شعريه للشاعر الراحل الامير عبد
الله الفيصل ضمن جولات ادبيه تقيمها
اكاديميه الشعر العربي هذا العام ما بعد
ادونيس هو مشروع سعودي
ثقافي ادبي شعري
يرتبط
بالمكان التاريخيه التي تنتمي او الارث
التاريخي لهذه الارض ارض الجزيره العربيه
التي تمتحن في اقفاص اللغه حراك ادبي
ثقافي تعيشه السعوديه هذه السنوات
واستقطاب لابرز الادباء والمثقفين حراك
وقوده التفاعل والاهتمام الكبير من جميع
الاوساط من جده اسامه القاسم العربيه
مساء يوم الجمعه سيقترن الهلال بكوكب
الزهر خالد الزعل
[موسيقى]
اشهر منازل القمر الهلال واجملها البدر
والقمر قدرناه منازل حتى عاد كالعرجون
القديم والمع الاجرام السماويه كوكب
الزهره الذي يسميه العرب القدماء بالكوكب
الدري مثل نوره كمشكاه فيها مصباح المصباح
في زجاجه الزجاجه كانها كوكب دري وكوكب
الزهره يسمى عند العامه بنجمه العشاء ليش
لانه يظهر في وقت العشاء وفي مساء يوم
الجمعه سيقترن الاشهر بالاجمل سيقترن
الهلال بكوكب الزهره بشكل جميل ولافت
وبراق ناس على الناس تفرق مو كل نجوم
السماء
تبرق
[تصفيق]
وكوكب الزهره هو جمال الجهه الغربيه طوال
شهر رمضان وهو الكوكب الوحيد اللامع الذي
لا يرى قاطعنا الافق من الشرق الى الغرب
كحال الكواكب الثانيه ليش لانه واقع بيننا
وبين الشمس والعرب اسموه بالزهره لانه
يزهر بجماله وكانها لبهائها ولحسنها خلقت
من الياقوت والمرجان حارت حروف النور في
وصف التي اهوى واعجز حسنها
تبياني
[موسيقى]
يؤكد انها ارسال بريطانيا للقضاء في
اليورانيوم ينقل الصراع لمرحله جديده
اقرار قانون المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
والقوانين الاخرى يدعو الى مفوضيه
للانتخابات في الكويت ويؤكد ان البلاد
تسير في حلقه مفرغه
الرابعه تواكب التجارب البحثيه لرائدي
الفضاء السعوديين تمهيدا لرحله الفضاء
المقرره في مايو المقبل
مع حلول شهر رمضان 400 حافله تنقل
المعتمرين والزوار في مكه بشكل مجاني
ايتها الضاد الضاد
وجد تحتفي بعام الشعر العربي بامسيال
للشاعر السوري الشهير
نهايه الرابع الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]